dmx was definitely not an artist to me
he was a brother
he was a friend he was actually my best
friend
dmx's family and friends said their
final goodbyes to the late rapper
i stand before everyone today to simply
share a love story
our story i never thought that our story
would end as subtly as it has
but it's filled with pages upon pages of
memories
and kept alive within my heart on sunday
bet remembers dmx homegoing celebration
was full of emotional moments
[Music]
dmx's children paid tribute by sharing
special moments spent with their father
whenever i was out with my father he was
so proud to hear
about all i was doing in my life whether
it was school
and even the smallest little
accomplishment when my father passed
someone
um messaged me something that really
stuck with me
they said the hardest thing ever is
accepting that this earth still rotates
without the people you
of you are more than my dad you are an
icon
a legend i know you're up there talking
with god because they say all dogs go to
heaven
you bless the world with your talent
gave hope to the hopeless
all while trying to find hope for
yourself and no one noticed
swiss beats was a long time friend and
collaborator of dmx's
he recalled the special bond they shared
from the beginning of their friendship
i remember starting him to share his
house
you know sitting there coming up with
the plays
doing things he wasn't supposed to he
told me so many
stories so i tend to get emotional and i
tend to
you know feel how i feel sometimes about
it because
i really really listened to my brother's
words it wasn't about
anything other but you know his truth
that that he trusted me with
i just wanted to always protect him it
just felt like my job to protect him
even
friends and family were like man why you
go so hard for x it's because me and him
just built a personal relationship
swizz beats opened up about the layers
of dmx that not everyone could see
the key thing is he maintained his
passion he maintained his strength
you know he was barking and growling on
stage
to hide the real things he was going
through
you know x was a very loving teddy bear
type of guy
he probably mad at me for saying that
dog but i'm you know he
he was a sweetheart he was the most
giving and loving person that i ever met
surrounded by
all the late rappers friends and family
he left everyone with a heartfelt
message
and what the mission needs to be after
dmx is laid to rest
i'm just happy to see everybody here in
good spirits
and in good health and his kids
are now our kids and we're gonna ride
this out forever
blessings in love
you